I want you to imagine it’s 1992,
and you're talking to a telecoms expert.
She tells you that mobile phone
text messaging is going to fundamentally
change the way we communicate.
You think,
"But we use our phones
just for voice calls.
Why on Earth am I going to go from this
to tapping on a screen
with my fingers and my thumbs?"
In 1992, the first text message was sent.
After a slow start,
text-based services exploded.
This paved the way
for the smartphone revolution
that we have seen today.
And other technology trends
have followed that same curve.
I know how much we struggle to comprehend
and predict what
“exponential change” means.
Because I was at Nokia in 1993
when that technological
revolution started.
And now as head of UN Climate Change,
I'm here to tell you that what was true
for mobile phones back in 1992,
and other revolutionary shifts,
is also true for climate action today.
To make climate action
go from linear to exponential pace,
it's not just my job to make it happen.
It's also your job, too.
We all know that climate impacts
are hitting harder and harder every day.
The ambition we need to see,
reducing emissions,
adapting to impacts
and providing the means
to address the crisis,
are severely lacking.
But just like technology,
public opinion has its tipping point.
In my youth, I campaigned
against apartheid.
Participating in that fight,
those demonstrations,
meant shaking the foundations of a system
many thought would never change.
But then, one day,
after generations of slow progress,
the system changed.
The pressure was too great.
The point tipped.
We're here in Detroit,
the heart of car manufacturing.
Take a look at this graph.
Electric vehicle sales
are expected to increase
to become 70 percent by 2030.
Another example.
Solar energy.
Between 2010 and 2020,
we moved from 20 gigawatts
of solar energy installed
to 150 gigawatts.
Now, just three years later,
that number is expected to increase
to 350 gigawatts per year.
And by 2030,
that number is expected to increase
again to 1,000 gigawatts per year.
Change can come fast.
But time isn't on our side.
We have less than seven years
between now and 2030
to halve our global emissions.
So the question is: Will those tipping
points come soon enough
to avoid the catastrophic impacts
of climate change?
At out current speed,
change will come too late
to limit warming to 1.5 degrees Celsius.
That is the hard truth
of the global stocktake
that will be completed
by the UNFCCC this year.
But this is where you come in.
You may think it's not
your responsibility to drive change.
You may not think you have
the power to make this happen.
Both of those statements are wrong.
At the UNFCCC,
we are the custodians of the process.
We're the defenders of the agreements.
We are the champions of parties
and the agreements that they make.
But globally,
we're collectively in a state
of what the author Kim Stanley Robinson
describes as “The Dithering.”
A state of indecision
and a state of inaction
in the face of a global crisis.
But countries will agree
to boost in action.
If enough people encourage them to do so.
Contact your representatives and ask them
what they are doing to deliver.
What plans do they have
to ensure that your concerns
on climate count?
That direct action does work.
I have seen positions change
time and time again
when citizens engage directly.
Every time you buy something,
ask yourself the question:
Is this the greenest option?
Ask those around you
about their green choices.
Learn new things.
Educate and mobilize.
The power of human organization
can result in change.
Which brings me to my final point.
You don't have to be a politician
or a prominent business person
to make a significant contribution.
Climate action calls for all skill sets.
Ask yourself:
What am I passionate about?
What am I good at?
What am I training for?
Then ask yourself the question,
how can I apply this
to the climate crisis?
And do exactly that thing.
If you act,
the exponential change
that is needed will happen.
I thank you.
(Applause)